[Musique]
contrairement aux pommes l'argent ne
pousse pas dans les arbres répété
françois legault encore aujourd'hui une
attaque dirigée contre ses adversaires
libéraux et solidaire ce qu'on voit dans
les deux cas de financiers qui ont été
déposées ce inquiétant parce que ce pôle
tendue aux cowboys avec l'argent des
québécois le chef de la caq affirme que
son cadre financier lui est responsable
sur un horizon de quatre ans ses
promesses entraînerait des nouvelles
dépenses de 29 milliards de dollars la
majeure partie servirait à financer
diverses mesures comme des baisses
d'impôts pour que les québécois puissent
faire face à l'augmentation du coût de
la vie actuellement la principale
préoccupation des québécois pensent que
tous les députés l'ont vu sur le terrain
c'est l'inflation la chaîne gestion et
finances publiques est une priorité dans
son rapport pré électorale le mois
dernier eric girard prévoyez un retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire dans cinq ans cet
objectif est d'ailleurs maintenu dans le
cadre financier de la cac or les
déficits serait plus important que prévu
l'an prochain il frôlerait les 8
milliards de dollars car la caq
dépenserait plus mais elle n'aurait pas
beaucoup de nouvelles sources de revenus
hormis la croissance anticipée de
l'économie avec le stimuli fiscale que
nous proposons pour 2023 c'est certain
que ça va soutenir l'économie sa mort
est aidé dans un contexte économique
instable où plusieurs ont le mot
récession sur les lèvres c'est au tour
de françois legault de goûter à la
médecine de ses adversaires la caq ses
ventes des revenus qui sont basés sur
absolument rien sinon que du vent
malheureusement il nous a annoncé qu'il
irait puis j'ai ça dans le fonds des
générations
donc il va aller chercher l'argent qui
est destiné aux jeunes pivots transfert
et ce pour baisser les impôts moi j'en
reviens pas que y ait même pas le mot
changement climatique dans son cadre
financier
le manque maintenant que les cadres
financiers du parti québécois et du
parti conservateur du québec que tous
les deux promettent de dévoiler avant la
tenue du premier débat des chefs qui
aura lieu dans cinq jours ici alexandre
duval radio-canada rougement